America everyone knows it's the greatest
nation on earth and our leaders are the
greatest leaders on earth but did you
know there are other countries that are
not America and each of them has a
leader of its very own let's take a
moment to meet one our ongoing series
other countries presidents of the United
States
this week's leader Tony Abbott Prime
Minister of Australia
the island nation famed for its bouncing
kangaroos and bloomin onions its current
leader hardline right-wing Prime
Minister Tony Abbott who rose to power
promising to be pro-business and
religiously anti-immigration literally
religiously anti-immigration Jesus knew
that there was a place for everything
and and it is not necessarily everyone's
place to come to Australia exactly
Australia is for real Australians like
Tony Abbott who was born in London
England it's that kind of rhetorical
consistency that's won him the
admiration of his predecessors if tiny
evidence up to Prime Minister Australia
I mean you go say god help us god help
us tributes and song and the love of
Australia's children my mommy calls him
Tony down down the goods she thinks she
is so unlike dumb what is it about Tony
dumb-dumb that's led to his current
approval rating of 30% could it be that
he's personally insulted everyone else
in the country from women the health
laws of
to gauge how my sexuality how do you
feel about that
ah I probably felt a bit threatened to
anyone remotely oh this government's a
bit like the Irishman who lost 10 pounds
betting on the grand national and then
lost 20 pounds on the action replay to
elderly cancer-ridden phone sex workers
Tony Abbott has been filmed winking
during a radio show on the fixative 13
year old pensioner 3 chronic incurable
medical conditions two life-threatening
and I work on an adult six line to make
ends meet two incredibly yes Tony Abbott
has been caught out seemingly insulting
a Queensland soldier killed in
Afghanistan after being told about the
complications of the firefight
this is mr. Abbott's reaction
sometimes does happen luckily Tony
Abbott is a master of words and can talk
himself out of any situation loca Soulja
has died and you shouldn't be trying to
turn this into a subsequent media circus
how's that turning into a media circus
well tell me what's the context in of
his out of context what is the context
yeah outside attorney
I've given you the response she deserved
yes Tony Abbott knows one panicked
panting expression is worth a thousand
words and what away with words Tony
Abbott has no one however smart
I however well educated however
experienced is the suppository of all
wisdom but if anyone is the suppository
of wisdom surely it's Tony Abbott a man
who always knows exactly what to say or
not to say and who's one exactly is much
respect from his constituents as he
deserves